Mel Gibson hasn't exactly had the smoothest
couple of decades.
He's got something of a controversial past
to say the least, including numerous allegations
of racism, bigotry, and domestic abuse.
Although there was once a time when any Mel
Gibson film was pretty much guaranteed to
draw a crowd, that's not really the case nowadays,
and it's clear that the acclaimed actor and
Oscar-winning director's star has fallen very
far indeed.
"Oh, you wanna see crazy?
I'll show you-"
Nonetheless, Gibson now looks to be making
strides toward a comeback.
The internet is awash with praise for Gibson's
latest movie appearance in Boss Level, a sci-fi
action Hulu original.
Gibson isn't the film's lead, and he wasn't
behind the helm as its director either, but
fans and critics alike are absolutely loving
the flick, with some taking special note of
his performance.
By all accounts, Boss Level is a fun and gleefully
violent action film that joins the ever-growing
list of movies to have utilized the time-loop
story trope.
Frank Grillo, probably most familiar for his
role as Crossbones in the MCU, stars in Boss
Level as Roy Pulver, a Special Forces soldier
stuck in an endless time loop, forced to relive
the day of his death over and over again.
Meanwhile, Naomi Watts plays Roy's estranged
wife Jemma, and her boss is the defense contractor
Colonel Clive Ventor, played by Gibson himself.
In the midst of Roy's many time loops, a suspicious
death puts Ventor on his radar — and from
there, the two are set on a collision course
filled with all the explosions, car chases,
and gunfights that you could possibly hope
for.
Now, it's true that both casual movie-lovers
and professional critics seem to agree that
Gibson's new movie isn't exactly breaking
new ground when it comes to the time-loop
sub-genre.
That said, Boss Level is still unique among
such films for just how fun and unapologetically
bloody it can get.
As a result, plenty of viewers have taken
to Twitter to praise the new sci-fi action
flick.
One user told their followers:
"If you like stuff like Groundhog Day, Russian
Doll, Happy Death Day(2 u), then check out
Boss Level on Hulu."
Meanwhile, another Twitter user called the
movie:
"A hugely entertaining time loop action film
[...[ bloody and inventive with its tongue
placed firmly in cheek."
That same user also pointed out that Mel Gibson
ought to have been given a little more to
do in the movie — which is pretty telling
praise in a world where many would agree that
less Mel Gibson is definitely better than
more.
Putting a little smack talk twist on their
praise for the movie, another Twitterer said:
"BOSS LEVEL is like if GUNS AKIMBO was Good."
And, although they didn't give a full verdict
on the movie itself, one user highlighted
the sheer bloodiness of Boss Level — and
especially Frank Grillo's endless, gory deaths
— writing:
"My theory as to why Frank Grillo made Boss
Level...
To dethrone Sean Bean with the most on screen
deaths with just 1 movie."
Surprisingly enough, it isn't just the fans
who are loving Boss Level, either.
While the film's current Rotten Tomatoes score
of 72 percent indicates that not all the critics
loved the movie, it's still managed to garner
some pretty noteworthy critical praise.
At IndieWire, critic Christian Blauvelt wrote
that:
"Grillo gives Boss Level the thing most video
game movie riffs lack: a pulse."
While Gary Goldstein of the Los Angeles Times
said:
"[Boss Level] takes a well-worn gag and injects
energy, showing the genre is still a game
worth playing."
Writing for Den of Geek, Bernard Boo said
of the movie:
"It's a lot of fun to watch and one of the
best showcases of Grillo's 'very particular
set of skills' yet."
While Decider's Johnny Loftus was more economical
with his words, writing simply:
"It's outrageous.
Just go with it."
So it really does seem like Boss Level might
be something of a surprise hit — and at
least some of that is down to Mel Gibson himself.
Just what it means for his troublesome career,
however, remains to be seen.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.